Millennials are drinking less coffee
thus proving that I'm not it's tea time
for us millenials according to a new
YouGov survey 42 percent of Americans
under the age of 30 prefer to drink tea
with an identical 42 percent saying they
prefer coffee further 27 percent of
Millennials only drink tea that's a huge
difference from their parents and
grandparents with 70 percent of
Americans over the age of 65 saving
vapor for a damn fine cup of coffee
alright so first questions first
how caffeinated are you right this very
second not nearly enough
are you caffeine freaks I know you
drinking coffee in the morning but
you're not nearly enough Bryn Molly
won't let me drink coffee in the morning
because she says I get too hyper and
then I bounce off all the walls and I
started like yeah right you have like a
natural caffeine thing in your brain
yeah yeah but let me tell you when I do
have a coffee yeah I have to sneak one
and then I come in and then Molly's like
you drink your coffee didn't you and
then he did so right now I have no
coffee and this is my normal sort of
Stacy I wish I had yeah now we are
hitting I think we're hitting three
generations here because I'm technically
Generation X now we were discussing
before you're probably Generation Y
right like that's or you want a
millennial ish what but you're full-on
millennial what's with you crazy kids
getting off the caffeine you're drinking
more tea that's what they're telling us
yeah well you guys didn't maybe grow up
with like all of the different types of
caffeine ways you can get caffeinated or
you got redbull what is pretty gross so
so far away it wasn't sorry I think we
had milk or water right realities I've
never liked the taste of coffee coffee
always been a means to an end for me
which is the caffeine part of it so
having other options that are equally
effective to that end and it tastes
better I'm just gonna go for right he
tastes way better than coffee and if I'm
getting the same sort of caffeinated
experience from it then I'd much rather
drink something I actually enjoy I want
to know what constitutes the tea part
because I see a lot of people in America
drinking those like giant Arizona tea
64-ounce them to that count because
that's just sugar that is pure
two integrated evil yeah because I don't
I don't see a lot of people on the
street drinking even Millennials
drinking like a cup of fine cup of tea I
haven't seen that this isn't Downton
Abbey it's not downs IV side of them
maybe that's happened no but there's
like a dirty hippie Yorba mate' crew
which is like that I drank a yerba mate
a this morning I died and it was given
to me by one of the kids on this staff
yeah do you drink do you guys think that
the tea thing with the Millennials has
something to do with it's like a
counterculture thing to Starbucks like
Starbucks became so big it's on
literally every corner they just opened
one right over here I'm guilty of go to
Starbucks all the time - I'm gonna see a
ttle it's a brand loyalty of mine but
now when I go I'll sometimes get coffee
sometimes get tea because honestly the
coffee there isn't great I like that
bitter like grass-fed butter coconut oil
coffee you guys all right so last
thought on this just sort of wider about
Millennials in general I feel like
Millennials get a lot of [ __ ] like
everyone there's all these articles
written constantly Oh Millennials selfie
and then there's that right there there
was me kind of thing but to me I see
young people at least the people that
I'm interacting with on Twitter and on
this show that they're they're
incredibly connected they're paying
attention to what's out there they have
new access to news and all the things
that we're trying to bring them like I
think they get a lot of [ __ ] do you do
you agree yeah of course but so do you
old people so but we have we have this
incredible demographic of mostly
Millennials on this overwhelming
majority on riot that are Millennials
and like I've been so blown away and
inspired and I'll be the first to defend
the generation is being connected being
socially aware being kind compassionate
caring about the other people I think
being fully aware of you know things
like bullying rights you know body image
things all of those things are we really
have people who are responding and young
people and Millennials overwhelmingly
who really want to do something and make
a difference so I say let them drink tea
I don't think I can finish it up any
cleaner than that
are you a millennial how caffeinated are
you right now let us
in the comments right down below